delicious but be careful if you see it
in someone's chinese household it's
probably been there for 10 years
check the expiration date
hey guys i'm jimmy yo yang and these are
some of my favorite asian snacks
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
the white rabbit this has became like a
cultural icon the great thing about this
that confuses a lot of people is after
you unwrap this right
you have
a film of paper and you can actually eat
this paper i always thought like my
parents was praying playing a trick with
me it's like oh just eat the paper but
no
it melts in your mouth it's probably the
whole thing and and you
eat the whole candy and you gotta warm
it up
with your mouth it's kind of like a
like a hard thing that you suck on i
probably shouldn't even say that this
thing really spans a lot of generations
in chinese it says right here it's big
rabbit
very great candy
hey
look at these like little chinese
firecracker looking thingies
they're called hall flakes i never knew
what it was called in english it's a
stack
of like these red candies and you just
eat it a little bit of time
it's very good
i think it's from the
a chinese food called hawthorne so it's
called hulk and it's very sweet
kind of sour kind of tangy i can eat
like so many like growing them in hong
kong it was like what i ate it was
really legit i was surprised i haven't
seen this since i was like maybe 10
years old delicious
ah yes
this is the vita vita lemon tea this is
uh iced tea basically in a paper box a
lot of stuff came in paper boxes yeah
this is what you get every day in school
in hong kong man
it's very very good and it makes the
sound after you finish drinking it like
like after you take a sip
you hear that
and it's made in hong kong i guess this
is like the go-to hong kong company you
guys should definitely go try to vita
soy milk too that's one of my favorite
ly soy milks delicious
throw the whole box in if it doesn't
break the table
oh look at this
this is a gold mine of lychee coconut
jelly you can see this in every chinese
household there's a tub that's where
i've been reused at something else to
contain i don't know and a number of
items but this
is lychee oh it's sealed i've never seen
a new box i didn't know the seal existed
it's uh just been sitting in your family
for like 10 years and you can only have
one this is like this is like really
gold it's precious you know it's just a
beautiful jello with a couple like pulpy
lychee in it just pop it in your mouth
it's delicious and it's still like kind
of juicy i'm gonna i'm gonna eat one
more because i don't think like my
parents ever let me eat like more than
one this is like good [ __ ]
this is the good [ __ ]
delicious but be careful if you see this
in someone's chinese household it's
probably been there for 10 years
check the expiration date
my dad grew up eating these in shanghai
i know what it's called in shanghainese
it's called sajimu i think in candidates
called sake ma something like that i
think it's a fried rice dough but then
you jam pack it together so basically a
rice krispie treat i've had homemade
ones that's like a little more chewy
there's some packaged ones that's like
you know a little more crunchy or like
the flavor is a little different this
one's a little darker than what i'm used
to is this a chocolate flavor flavor one
or no the don't mean whole package
oh this is uh
egg yolk flavor it says black sugar uh
hey tong you know so this is probably
why it's like a dark sugar
it's very nice i like it but my this is
like one of my dad's favorites you know
what i got
chinese snack
so this i brought out for my own
personal stash because i love it so much
it's actually been open it's half eaten
but it's the animal crackers that i grew
up on and had seaweed flavor it's one of
my favorite snacks ever it's how i learn
my animals it's very japanese so you can
learn both english and japanese in the
back can you see that bat ox giraffe
this one
it's a pelican i'm not even sure which
way is up or down but it's just an
interesting shape japanese snack is very
popular in hong kong maybe china in
general also there's hong kong's such a
small city state right a lot of the
stuff is imported from other asian
countries i used to collect like dragon
ball z cards pokemon cards and eat
japanese snacks
it's delicious it's a biscuit that's a
little sweet but it's really savory
because it has the seaweed on top this
is educational and delicious i highly
recommend it
this is one of my favorite brands wong
wong with this little guy it's like a a
weird guy with a terrible haircut
wearing a diaper this is what they call
like a snow rice cake oh it's a product
of taiwan see yet another place in asia
so you see that little snow on there
you know it's actually kind of like
crusted baked in frosting it's not like
those healthy rice cake you find in like
[ __ ] [ __ ] places like arowan for
like 25 then and then just scratches
your throat no no this is real delicious
rice cake which i'm sure is not as
healthy as the erwan stuff but [ __ ] em
you know i love these snacks they're so
crunchy so easy to eat very fluffy
uh-huh
[Music]
big fan
looks better this brand also
this is moon cake
i'm not even sure if this considers as a
snack but it's more like a
festive festive snack festive meal this
thing is very heavy it's very high in
calories just solid oh geez
okay very expensive these things could
be like a hundred bucks for like a box
of four in like the chinese markets and
they only sell it during the mid autumn
festival chong chaoti so this one has a
lotus seed paste with two golden salty
egg yolks so it's one of my favorite
flavors one of the most classic flavors
but this is what you give people as
gifts also very seasonal very
traditional
and delicious
thank you guys well i'm jimmy oyeng and
those were some of my favorite asian
snacks or just snacks how about that
that was pretty good right all right
hang on hang on hang on i'm gonna plug
some [ __ ] now my movie is coming out
called love heart it's a romantic comedy
starring your boy and amazing nina
dobrev on netflix all right those are my
favorite snacks
and i'm out of here
[Music]